>> We're proud to have Aaron Santos here,
the author of, "How Many Licks? Or How to
Estimate Damn Near Anything.”
So, Aaron is a local Ann Arbor resident.
He's not only an author, but a physicist,
and also an occasional actor and director.
So he's currently out doing some research
here at U of M.
Just to give you a little bit more background
about Aaron, he attended MIT where he got
his B.S. in physics.
After graduating, he taught physics and chemistry
in the Boston Public School system.
And then, he attended Boston University where
he actually had his Ph.D. in physics.
So, we're in the presence of a very smart
man.
So, like I said, currently he is studying
at U of M, the various nanoscale systems,
so maybe you could expand on that a little
bit.
And then, without further ado, just please
help me welcome our author, Aaron Santos.
>> [Clapping]
Aaron Santos: You guys want me to do without
this, or? Okay.
[pause]
Aaron Santos: Lindsay, can you hear me?
Is the camera going to be able to pick me
up fine?
Or should I use this one?
>> Maybe use that. Yeah. Sorry.
Aaron Santos: First of all, thank you all
for having me.
It's an honor to be here, but I have to say,
I'm a little bit nervous, because this is
kind of a new experience for me.
I'm not really used to the whole author thing.
And I haven't really given very many talks
on it.
So this is a little bit of an experiment for
me.
And it's not made easier by the fact that
the book that I wrote is essentially a book
of math problems.
So, trying to talk for an hour or so about
essentially just doing the math that you all
hated in high school.
It's really hard to make that interesting.
So I spent the last week really trying to
find a way to make this entertaining for you
guys.
So toward that end, I'm going to talk a little
bit about, first of all, why you want to do
the things like approximations, and why would
you want to calculate things.
I'll tell you a little bit about one method
that I used in the book to show how to approximate
just about anything.
And then, I'll give you a few hopefully fun
examples of that.
So, when I was putting this together, I was
thinking, "What -- you know, why did I want
to write a book on this?
And what are the reasons?
And what did I want to get out of it?”
And the first thing I was thinking was that,
you know, doing math really helps you develop
critical thinking and reasoning skills.
But, that was also the most boring reason
I could come up with.
Of course, that's the reason why you take
math in high school, but, you know, it's also
not very exciting.
But one of the more practical reasons for
doing it is, it provides a good idea culture.
So anybody who's watched the news lately has
heard a lot about the health care debate.
You hear a lot of things like "socialism"
and, you know, "killing your grandma" and
things like that.
But, when you get down to it, the health care
problem, and health care in general, is really
just a math problem.
You have X number of people that are in the
United States.
Some fraction of them are going to get sick
during the next six months.
And it's going to cost an average amount to
pay for that sickness.
So we just spread out the average.
By just averaging over all people, we just
get a rough estimate of how much we're going
to have to pay for everybody.
It's a very simple math problem.
It's not very complicated at all.
So really, if we're going to solve things
like this, it's helpful to just be able to
go through the math, and have a very informed
public opinion on things like this.
So that's kind of a practical reason for doing
these kinds of problems.
And then, the last one is really that it's
just kind of a fun game to play.
And I'll give you an example of what I mean.
So I was at the original Spiderman movie.
I was sitting there with a friend.
And Tobey Maguire is on screen.
He's, "Shoot the web. Shoot the web. Shoot
the web.”
And if you look at it, the web's like this
thick.
And it's going, you know, 30 meters out from
him.
And the friend sitting next to me was just
like, "How much does he have to eat to produce
all that web?”
And nobody actually ever sits down and takes
the time to calculate it, unless you're a
geek like me.
But that's basically the types of things that
I do.
It's akin to doing -- I imagine doing with
a Sudoku or a crossword puzzle for anybody
else.
So, I want to talk a little bit about how
exactly we go about calculating something
like this Spiderman problem.
And one method that you could use to do that
is something called the "Fermian Approximation.”
So Enrico Fermi, who was an Italian physicist
-- and a little bit of trivia for you -- half
of the particles in the universe were named
after him.
Well, he popularized this method of computing
things to within an order of magnitude.
The approximation varies with -- .
It's called Fermian approximations.
And basically is, he would go up to his students
and say, "You.
Tell me the number of piano tuners in Chicago.”
And of course, you know, I can tell by the
blank stare on your face that you have no
idea how to do that.
And that's basically what his students thought.
But what he showed was that through very simple
approximations, you can actually calculate
this and just about anything else.
Just by starting to look at, you know, using
very simple math to do these order of magnitude
estimates.
So the first step in this process is to use
what you know or look up what you don't know.
So I can start by saying, "Well, you know,
I can't figure out offhand just how many -- I
don't know offhand just how many piano tuners
are in Chicago.
But I know roughly five percent of my friends,
you know, or like one out of 20 of my friends
owns a piano.
If I go down my Facebook page I say, "Well,
this person's musical.
This one's not. This one's not. This one's
not."
And five percent seems like a reasonable number.
Now, you say, "Well, you know, you can be
way off on that.”
You're true. I could be way off on that.
But I know that it's less than 50 percent
of people, because that would just be like,
half of my friends don't own a piano.
So it's definitely less than that.
But I know it's also more than one out of
every 200 people, because I know quite a few
people with pianos and it would be odd to
have that few pianos.
So I know that that's somewhere in the bounds
of what you'd expect to be reasonable.
And you basically go down the line.
You write down all the things you know.
So the next thing is that, if you have a piano,
generally get it tuned about once a year.
Now, if you're very neglectful, you might
get it tuned once every three years.
But you're not going to get it tuned once
every 30 years.
So we're in the bounds of what's reasonable.
You're also not going to get it tuned, you
know, five times a year.
Because that would be very expensive, unless
you're somebody who really plays it often.
Most people are just getting it tuned, you
know, one or two times a year.
You go a little bit further.
You say, "Maybe a piano tuner tunes two pianos
a day.”
And it's helpful to know the number of people
in Chicago is about three million people.
You could just look that up on Google, or
you could know that roughly the number of
people in a big city is about a million people,
but Chicago is a pretty big city, so maybe
it has a few million people in it.
So these are all
the things that you want to start off with.
And the next thing you want to do is, just
like you did in high school chemistry class,
you just want to cancel units.
So if I wanted to calculate the number of
pianos, well, I know there's three million
people in Chicago.
I know there's one piano for every 20 people.
So I just cancel units in the same way that
I did canceling grams per mole or whatever
you did in high school.
Yeah. It's the same exact thing.
So two divided by two is one.
Three divided by three is one.
And people divided by people is one.
And then you just do that excessively.
So people will cancel with people, pianos
will cancel with pianos, years cancel with
years, days cancel with days, tunings cancel
with tunings.
And if you multiply all these numbers together,
at the end of the day, you calculate, you'll
get about 200 piano tuners in Chicago.
So starting from absolutely nothing, you really
can just build up and figure out a way to
come up with a reasonable answer.
Now, you might ask, "Well, how do you know
that this is anything close to the actual
number?”
Well, if you look in the Chicago Yellow Pages,
there's about 40 listings for piano tuners.
So we're off by less than a factor of ten.
And we're probably even a little bit better
than that, because not every tuner is going
to pay for a listing.
And the ones that are listed might have several
tuners in them.
So we're actually pretty close in this regard.
So, next, I'm going to get into -- what I
hope will be -- some fun examples for you
guys.
I'm going to start with a disclaimer that,
I just want to say, These are all just estimates.
I'm making no claims about their factualness.
So, please don't sue me if I'm getting anything
wrong.
And we're going to start with this guy, which
I'm assuming most of you all know him.
For those of you who don't know him, this
is the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man.
I suppose you could call him the character
who appears in the last enacted battle in
Ghostbusters -- we were always trying to follow
them -- but the Ghostbusters movie leaves
one question that's unresolved.
How long would it take to eat it?
So again, you want to start with what you
know.
If you take a marshmallow, you know it's about
an inch tall, maybe half an inch wide.
So from that, I can calculate the volume of
the marshmallow.
Just by taking an inch by half-an-inch by
half-an-inch.
And if you look on the back of a package of
marshmallows, you could find that there are
about 25-calories in a marshmallow.
So, putting those things together, I could
say that there's about 75-calories for every
cubic inch of marshmallow.
Now, looking at Mr. Stay Puft, he's about
the size of a ten-story building.
Each story of the building is going to be
about 14 feet.
Therefore he's going to be about 140 feet
tall.
He's going to be a little less than half of
that amount wide.
So we'll say 60 feet wide.
We'll say 60 feet deep.
And from that, I just multiply all those numbers
together.
I get his total volume, which will be on the
order of 500,000 cubic feet.
And I can also convert that to inches.
So then the last part is, like we said before,
just cancel the units, multiply "calories
per inches cubed" by "inches cubed," you get
the number of calories, about 64 billion calories.
Now, if you take the FDA recommended 2000
calories per day, now we can calculate it
would take about 80,000 years to eat it.
So this is a pretty fun example, I hope.
But I know there was a little bit of math
there.
And math can tend to lose people, so I want
to hopefully get your attention back.
So our next problem we'll be talking a little
bit about sex.
And since you all work at Google.
I can only assume you're thinking one thing.
But I'm here to tell you that there's more
things in life than just coming up with the
world's greatest search--.
So there's a problem with this calculation.
It's hard to start with what you know.
Because there's many different types of people.
And as you can see by the wide variety of
people that I've included in this slide, some
of them are going to be having more sex than
others.
In some cases, a lot more sex than others.
But we need to come up with some numbers for
this.
So we're going to use upper and lower bounds
to get a rough idea of where the average amount
of sex that people are having.
So the question we're considering is, "How
many people are having sex right now?”
Now, if I ask each of you how often you had
sex, each of you would give me a different
number.
Now, there's a lot of different people in
the world.
There's everything from babies to really old
people.
You guys all look like mostly you're in your
20's and many of you are probably in committed
relationships.
So you're going to be having sex a lot more
than most people.
But that being said, the babies really bring
the number down.
So on average, people are probably not going
to be having sex once a day.
At the other end of the spectrum, the people
who are having sex can have a lot of sex.
So you're probably going to be having sex
more than once a year.
So, on average, you'd expect that once a month
seems like a reasonably good number.
It fits within the bounds of what we would
consider acceptable, at least by my standards.
So the next question is, you want to ask,
"Well how long does a typical sexual encounter
last?”
Well -- ten hours, at least if you trust your
Viagra commercials -- seems a little excessive.
If your sex is lasting ten hours, you should
probably call your doctor about that.
So that one's out.
Now, if your sex is only lasting ten seconds,
we should probably just skip this one, you
know and not even count it. Don't add.
So ten minutes seems like a reasonable amount
of time for a typical sexual encounter.
So, if you take ten minutes and divide that
into a month and get your units to cancel,
you'll find out that people are roughly having
sex .02 percent of the time.
Or put another way, the probability that any
of you in this room are having sex at this
instant is about .02 percent.
So I take that fraction and multiply that
by the 6.7 billion people that you have on
the Earth.
You find that about two million people are
having sex at any given instant on the planet.
So I know what you're thinking, "This is fun
for Marshmallow men and sex problems, but,"
you're probably thinking, "Is this actually
useful for anything?”
So, to answer that question, you know, I talked
a little bit about how you can use this in
health care and government policy, but another
thing that's been in the news lately is the
energy crisis and How are we going to supply
energy as we run out of fossil fuels?
What's a cleaner more efficient way of doing
that?
So you might want to ask, "Well, how much
area would it take to just tile some large,
you know, section of desert with solar panels
and Do we have enough space to get all of
our energy with solar power?”
So to do this one, most of us don't have facts
about solar power stored away unless we do
research in that area.
So it's helpful to do a quick Google search
just to find out some numbers.
And doing that, we can find -- there's actually
a mistake in this slide.
It should be 3.2 times 10 to the 12 watts
used by Americans.
-- That's the amount of power that we use
at any given time.
And if you look at the amount of sunlight
that's actually hitting the Earth, you'll
find that there's about 650-watts per meter
squared.
So roughly the size of your windshield is
getting hit with 650 watts of power every
second, which is why your car gets hot if
you park it in the sun for too long.
So I can use these numbers to calculate how
much power I'll get now.
But, unfortunately, even the best solar panels
are only about 40 percent efficient.
And this is even assuming that you have the
best, top-of-the-line, just-coming-out-of-research-labs
solar panels.
So again, you just do the mess in that part.
You take the 3.2 x 10 to the 12 watts that
you need, divide that by the amount of energy
that you're getting now, and you'll find that
you'll need about 4600 square miles of area
just to power all the United States.
And that's about the size of Rhode Island.
Now, obviously the good people of Rhode Island
probably don't want to give up their state
just so they can power all the other states.
So there's a lot of different people who are
thinking about, you know, Where can we actually
put these?
There's like a Solar Roads Project, where
people are saying, "We should tile the roads
with solar panels.”
When you have the power of these approximations
at hand, you can start to think about how
to solve these problems in a practical and
efficient way.
So I'm going to do one more problem, and then,
I'm going to end with the age-old question
-- this is also where my book gets its title
-- How many licks does it take to get to
the tootsie roll center of a tootsie pop?
So again, you want to start with things that
you know.
So I have somewhere the deep, dark recesses
of my pocket a tootsie pop.
As you can see tootsie pops are about an inch
thick.
So to get to the tootsie roll center, it's
going to be about a little less than a centimeter
to actually hit the tootsie pop.
Now, if I lick it, [licking] you can tell
it's been licked, because you can see there's
a little bit -- aside from the saliva -- you
can tell it just changes the shape of the
dome.
Now, I'm going to hand this to you.
So go for it.
That is all you if you want it and you think
I'm healthy.
Well, that might be well to doing some Google
searches to find out about my health background.
You can just barely tell it's been licked.
All right?
I can hand that to you, and you are not going
to want to eat it yourself.
So it makes sense to assume that the amount
of material that I remove from the surface
of the tootsie pop is just barely the amount
that I can see.
And if you look up online the smallest resolution
of the human eye can see things for now about
ten microns, which is about ten thousand times
smaller than a centimeter.
So all I have to do is divide the distance
I have to travel by the distance removed per
lick and I will get about 800 licks.
Now again, you might want to check the factualness
of this.
This is a true story.
I had a friend in college who actually sat
down and counted the number of licks it takes.
Now, of course, it's going to depend a little
bit on how big your tongue is, and you know,
how much saliva you have, things like that.
But they got 900 licks, and I got 800.
So I feel like I'm pretty close, definitely
within a power of ten.
So with that, I'm going to end here, and I
will take questions from you guys if you have
any.
>> [Clapping]
Q So what made you decide to write this for
your book?
Aaron Santos: That's a good question.
It was during my graduate quals, and the Fermi
problem was just something that -- it was
one of the problems on the qualifier exam.
And I just got enough of preparing for that,
I said, "Hey, this would make a good book.”
It was that in mind.
Q Is there a real life experience where you
estimated something that turned out to be
really valuable for more than just?
Aaron Santos: Yes. Plenty, actually.
So whenever you're doing -- this would be
useful for you guys too.
If you want to figure out how fast something
you're -- do takes.
You always want to do some rough estimate
on it.
And in physics, a lot of times you don't know
-- you have a very little information about
where you're supposed to be looking for something.
So an experimentalist will want to know where
to set their dial.
And to do that -- the best way to do that
is, just have a rough estimate of where you
are looking to see whatever phenomenon you
are searching for.
And doing computational physics -- that's
something I do a lot.
I try and calculate.
In the introduction, you mentioned that I
study nano particles and nanoscale self-assembly.
So if you're trying to get something to self-assemble,
a lot of times it happens in a rare event.
So you want to know how long your simulation
is going to run.
You don't want to run a simulation once a
month and not get any data and then never
be able to take your thesis or paper out of
it.
So it's something that I use in research every
day.
[pause]
Q [inaudible]
Aaron Santos: Well, the math is always the
same and the ______ version is always the
same.
So it's the same math but just with bigger
numbers.
But one of the things that I think if you
do enough of these sort of problems is, it
gives you an appreciation.
You start to get what I call "numerical landmarks"
in number space.
You know, that you can spend a thousand dollars
a day with -- if you have a million dollars
you can spend a thousand dollars a day for
like three years.
But if you have a billion dollars, you can
spend a thousand dollars a day going back
to the time of like Christ.
So you start to -- big numbers and small numbers
are just like anything else.
Once you've worked with them enough, you kind
of, I guess, build a conception for how big
they are.
So another thing you can -- another example
is, numbers of stars in the sky or how big
the universe is or how long the universe has
been around.
And these are all things that physicists estimate
all the time.
It's basically the same thing that they're
doing there.
[pause]
Q I have a question back here.
So one thing that we do a lot here at Google
is, we try and forecast what our advertisers
will be spending and how we may be able to
get that impact and help build their business
even more.
So do you have any suggestions or tips on
how, you know, how better to forecast?
Aaron Santos: How to better forecast.
Well, I don't know very much about advertising
or business in general.
But I think any time that you can sit down
and say you can set bounds on where things
are going to be.
You know, if company X wants to sell this
much product, and you have some rough idea
of how many advertisements you're going to
have to send out there 'til you hit somebody
who that advertisement is going to reach.
Then you can start to make some progress in
terms of where you should be directing things.
And then, this sort of approximation technique
would definitely be useful for that, much
like anything else.
But as far as specific examples for how to
be useful, I'm a little bit at a loss just
because I'm not familiar with that.
Q Did math always come easy to you, or do
you have tricks that you learned along the
way that help simplify it for you?
Aaron Santos: Does math always come easy for
me? Yes and no.
I think -- and you always learn tricks along
the way, right?
Your math teachers tell you that.
Every integer, multiply it by five or zero.
There's always these sort of tricks for it.
But I think for me, I think I was always pretty
good at math, but any time you can come up
with a trick, it's useful.
I can't point to anything in particular and
say, "That's what helped me get over the hump.”
I will say that, since I started doing a bunch
of these problems, I've been able to conceptualize
numbers a lot better than I was before.
So I think it's pretty useful for that regard.
[pause]
Aaron Santos: [in an incredulous tone] You
dropped it?
[laughter]
Aaron Santos: Now you're definitely not going
to want to lick it.
Yummy. Anybody else?
Q So do you always win contests where you
have to guess how many jelly beans are in
the jar?
Aaron Santos: I always come pretty close.
I don't always win.
That's, you know, usually they put it in some
odd-shaped container to try to fool you a
little bit.
This is a great -- in fact, if you're ever
at a carnival, now you know how they guess
the number of jelly beans in a jar.
There's a funny story about that actually.
So I was at -- like I said, I'm new to this
whole author thing -- so when I -- we were
going through different titles of the book,
and naturally, one of the original book titles
or covers that they had, was this jelly bean
jar filled and just that it's the standard
problem that you could use this for.
Well, the problem is, the title we really
wanted to use was, "Great Estimations," something
my friend came up with.
We thought it was like a clever pun.
But it turned out there was already a book
on the market called Great Estimations.
So, anyways, I was telling some people about
it, and they were like, "Don't worry.
Don't worry. Titles are not copyrightable.
You can get away with it.”
So then the first thing that my publishing
company gets back to me with the picture with
the cover is the exact same cover picture
as the book that's already published called
Great Estimations.
It was the jelly bean copy.
So as much as I wanted to use the jelly bean
example, I just couldn't do it, because there
was already a book out there on it.
[pause]
Aaron Santos: I'll say one more thing.
Calculating stuff is pretty fun, and you can
almost always get answers for questions.
But I stress "almost," because there have
been two or three problems that I could just
not come up with a good answer for.
I'll throw this one out there.
If any of you can solve it, please let me
know.
A friend of mine knew I was writing a book,
and they said, "I've got a great problem for
you.
If you took all the fish out of the ocean,
how much would it sink?”
So if any of you guys can come up with an
answer for this, please let me know.
I can probably come up with an average size
for a fish, but I just have no idea figuring
out how many fish there are in a population.
Any of you guys can come up with any other
way to figuring that one out, please let me
know, because that one has been bugging me
for years.
The other one I couldn't come up with? There
was one suggested by my sister, and it was,
"How many fireflies would it take to produce
the output of a lighthouse?”
And I just could not come up with a way of
estimating the light coming out of a firefly
without thinking that I was going to be really,
really far off.
So there's definitely -- I think there's always
-- There's always questions I won't even
attempt.
Like, somebody asks, "What's the probability
that God exists?”
It's not really a physical question.
Philosophers have been dealing with it for
centuries, and I'm not likely to interdict
anything useful.
So as long as it's a physical question, usually
you can come up with a pretty good estimate
for the answer.
Yeah, way back there.
Q So we were trying to solve a problem and
realized we were way off after you actually
looked at it?
Aaron Santos: Oh, yeah. All the time. All
the time.
Usually, though, it's because I do the math
wrong, as opposed to getting the method wrong.
It's usually -- because usually you can come
up with a pathway to get the answer, and then,
you just have to stick with that mistake.
And then, those are easy to correct.
Occasionally, you get -- one of the assumptions
I made in the beginning is that, it's important
to try to be careful about -- and that's usually
the time you're most skeptical them, about
the whole process.
And usually you think, "I can do math.
I'm not going to make any mistakes there.”
And that's where you run into problems.
>> [pause]
Aaron Santos: So I have to ask. Is this like?
I mean, I remember being in school.
And they would have like, you know, every
once in awhile, they'd have a convention where
you could get out of English class.
Is this like that for you guys?
Are you guys like trying to come up with questions,
because you don't have to go back to work
if you stay here?
Q I'd say there are more people who didn't
come, because they're stressed out about a
number of things.
I think part of our corporate culture faults
is not -- we don't get out of anything, and
you put bust your butt at night.
So we're probably like the more prudent ones
that are like try to work like everyone else.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: I'm not, but I see the video
arcade over there.
I see the piano over there.
I see what looks like some sort of ________
over there.
So I assume you guys are very busy and professional.
Oh. So you want me to estimate this.
Well, given by the numbers of chairs here,
I'd say about six by ten rows.
You could fit about a hundred people in here,
so I want to say maybe a hundred or so people.
150 people.
>> Within a power of ten.
Aaron Santos: What's the actual number?
>> About 63. Maybe more.
Aaron Santos: I'm going to be looking for
the opposite, if you're looking for more people.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: I'm not sure do you like ______
I'm not sure _____________ do for you guys
though.
I'd be _________ by your research stuff they
are pretty hard core on research.
Yeah.
They were the guys who were going around in
individual atoms and spelling out IBM on that.
So they're pretty ____.
It would be harder to spell out Google just
because they have more letters.
So any more questions? Things you would like
me to measure an estimate for.
Yeah?
Q So this is kind of silly, but I feel like
anyone going through the interview process
here they estimate.
Sometimes these are questions that you get
asked at interviews.
And I was like always afraid of teachers.
I know, I still haven't figured out if it's
meant to like throw you off, put you on the
spot, like show how you'd solve the problem,
or or think outside the box or what?
I know one that I got was, How would you estimate
the number of cans you would need to paint
half the houses in the U.S.
with?
Aaron Santos: Oh yeah. That's pretty standard.
Q Well, I guess so I'm kind of curious?
Aaron Santos: There's about 300 million people
in the U.S.
Presumably you can fit four people -- We'll
say three people to make the math a little
easier -- three people per home.
That's all.
About a hundred million homes.
Some people live in apartments or -- for now.
So let's see.
Where would you go from there?
The amount of paint. Oh.
I had a can of paint that painted basically
one wall in my apartment.
And I imagine an actual house would be anywhere
from 10 to 50 sizes of that wall.
So that gives you a rough idea of how much
paint you would need per house.
And then, you just multiply that by the number
of houses.
So, is that something close to what you said?
So, cool. So you already know what you are
doing.
Q We'll see.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: What? Did it have to be blue
or did I have to take into account there was
going to be a shortage of blue paint eventually,
or is that?
Q Yeah, so actually, the way I answered was
say that I would paint every single house,
but only paint half the house blue just because
I couldn't figure out how much paint it would
take to do a half of one house, so it's easier
to muliply it out.
Aaron Santos: Right. Right.
Q No one would probably want half of a house
painted, so I'm not sure if my answer is right.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: You were not popular here; are
you?
Q No, we have a pretty good group here.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: What's that?
Q In his office?
Aaron Santos: In the office?
Q In Ann Arbor.
Aaron Santos: In our state vs. university
feds.
Well, that would be hard to estimate, because
the state feds had to be a lot quieter, because
they know they're outnumbered.
Q Not me. Not here. Not in this office.
Aaron Santos: When are they playing State?
Q November third.
Aaron Santos: November third. Okay.
[inaudible]
Aaron Santos: I wonder if there are going
to be if is it as loud or three hundred people
louder by state like on campus like are they
just much more vocal? No?
It doesn't really matter anyway you guys don't
count, only out of state counts.
Q I have one last approximation question.
Aaron Santos: Sure.
Q So the Google logo is, you know, the colors
of legos.
So how many legos are there in the United
States?
Aaron Santos: Oh, Geez. That's a good question.
Well, you mean ever, or now?
Q Right now.
Aaron Santos: Right now.
Well, you can say roughly 50 percent of the
population is children.
So that's 150 million kids.
I know I had legos when I was a kid.
And since you guys work at Google, I'm going
to assume that there's a large factor here.
So I'm assuming most of you guys had legos.
But I'm not sure in general, the population
had.
Let's say 50 percent of the kids have legos.
You know, so I would say 150 million kids,
50 percent have legos -- We're talking about
individual lego pieces?
God, how many lego pieces did I have when
I was a kid? All right.
I built things that were like yea big.
So if you are taking lego pieces that are
this big, probably be 10 x 10 x 10.
So it'd be like 1,000 lego pieces per kid.
150 million kids, half of those.
I'm going to think about this one a little
bit more, but I would say on the order of
one to ten million legos pieces.
But it could get -- I want to think about
this one a little bit more, though, because
it could get thrown off, because rich kids
could have billions of legos.
So, you know, I definitely need to think about
that one more.
That's a good question.
Q They make big legos now, are these only
like 30 pieces per box.
Aaron Santos: I always assumed those were
for like, I mean, they're closer to Lincoln
loggers, because you couldn't do much with
them.
It's classic legos, or nothing for me.
That's where I draw the line.
And then megablocks don't count.
Those are like the cheap legos you got when
your parents didn't want to buy you the actual
legos.
That's all I have.
>> Well, thank you so much for coming.
>> [Clapping]